[Musica]
nel 1562 Jacopo Robusti detto Tintoretto
dipinge a Venezia un capolavoro della
storia dell'arte
si tratta del diluvio universale ed è un
Unicum perché al posto delle fiamme
dell'inferno
Tintoretto mette un enorme massa d'acqua
che schiaccia i dannati allontanandoli
per sempre dalla salvezza
Tintoretto non poteva saperlo ai tempi
ma aveva in qualche modo descritto un
presente che ci accomuna tutti e che
unisce la Germania
agli Stati Uniti Al Pakistan al
Madagascar all'Italia
un recente rapporto del pane e
intergovernativo sui cambiamenti
climatici che la massima autorità
scientifica in materia
ha scritto che la probabilità di eventi
di inondazione multipli cioè
straripamento di fiumi nubifragi
mareggiate è aumentata e continuerà ad
aumentare per effetto dei cambiamenti
climatici
ora gli scettici diranno che questi
eventi sono sempre più o meno avvenuti
continueranno ad avvenire lo stesso
invece no perché rispetto a prima come
comunità scientifica siamo in grado di
attribuire la quota parte di percentuale
del cambiamento climatico in un
determinato evento si chiama
attribuzione
e un'inchiesta del Guardian che ha
analizzato tutti gli studi scientifici
disponibili in materia di attribuzione
ha trovato che il 71% dei 504 e 20
naturali e cataclismi verificatisi negli
ultimi anni è più probabile o più severo
per effetto dei cambiamenti climatici e
anche qui non è proprio uguale
indipendentemente da quello che gli
scettici potrebbero pensare perché
questi eventi si abbattono su aree
vulnerabili costiere aree urbane Dove
vive il 40% della popolazione mondiale
si parla di cose di affetti di persone
di un presente che avviene oggi e non di
un futuro probabile più o meno lontano
siamo cresciuti penso tutti con historia
magistravite che è un motto direi quasi
un augurio Latino a studiare il passato
per comprendere il presente costruire un
futuro più luminoso migliore Vale
Praticamente per ogni aspetto della
nostra vita sia come gruppo società che
come individui da Mettiti la maglia
della salute perché sennò ti ammali come
quella volta a non mangiare gli spinaci
per quel pranzo importante perché poi
finiscono tra i denti e non va bene Ecco
quello è il sole Magistra la vita ma non
va bene
per quello che riguarda il clima almeno
da quando l'essere umano ha deciso di
impiantarvi la propria impronta per
sempre e lo sanno coloro che lavorano
nel settore immobiliare che è un
comparto economico costruito su un uso
molto intelligente dei dati studiare il
passato per capire dove andare a creare
nuove comunità dove la vita può essere
più comoda date certe caratteristiche
oggi non si può più fare e non
necessariamente perché Instagram rende
un posto più appetibile mettendone altri
nel dimenticatoio Ma perché esistono
questi eventi calamitosi questi eventi
disastrosi che rendono un luogo
completamente inaccessibile
un rapporto dell'organizzazione
meteorologica mondiale ha stimato che
negli ultimi 50 anni abbiamo vissuto
come comunità globale un fenomeno
disastroso al giorno con un conseguente
115 morti al giorno e 202 milioni di
dollari in danni economici al giorno è
un numero impressionante soprattutto
dato la situazione economica che stiamo
vivendo
e lo sanno Infatti i colossi di
assicurazioni e le riassicurazioni lo
sapete anche voi che avete tutte le
polizze loro hanno al loro interno Team
che studiano l'andamento dei cambiamenti
climatici e non lo fanno Da ieri perché
Nel 1974 un meterologo di nome Bernard
beards venne assunto da munichree il più
grosso colosso di riassicurazione
mondiale per studiare l'andamento degli
eventi disastrosi e Bers che era un uomo
di scienza aveva avuto un'illuminazione
che più o meno si può tradurre come i
disastri non sono naturali non stiamo
parlando ovviamente dei casi umani
perché per quelli ci servirebbe tutto un
altro tipo di Tik Tok stiamo parlando
del fatto che l'influenza umana può
alterare il corso naturale degli eventi
disastrosi rendendoli più Severi e più
frequenti
il che di per sé è certamente un
problema per ogni affetto naturale ma
prendiamone uno per tutti gli uragani
negli ultimi cinque anni
nell'atlantico si sono abbattute
tempeste di categoria 5 che la massima
per 5 anni consecutivi stabilendo un
record solo nel 2017 nel sud ovest degli
Stati Uniti e nei Caraibi si sono
abbattute tre tempeste tre uragani in un
unico mese causando danni superiori ad
un record stabilito solo nel 1992 da
luragano Andrew Per farvi capire di che
cosa parliamo l'uragano endrio aveva
causato 25 miliardi di dollari in danni
questi tre uragani in un unico mese Nel
2017 mi hanno causati 12 volte tanto il
conto lo potete fare da soli
Ma in effetti non siamo qui per parlare
di numeri non c'è proprio il clima
adatto siamo più qui piuttosto per
parlare di emozioni emozioni come paura
sgomento impotenza emozioni che sono
nascoste da questi numeri come se
fossero dentro una partitura ma rivelano
in qualche modo la moralità di una
specie quella umana che ha deciso di
usare e piegare la natura a proprio
piacimento senza calibrarne le
conseguenze il che di per sé è
completamente contrario a quello che
vorrebbe il buon senso perché il nostro
rapporto con la natura è di totale
dipendenza tutti lo sappiamo e alcuni ci
hanno fatto sopra un'intera fortuna come
ad esempio Antonio Vivaldi che nel 1725
descriverà l'esperienza della vita umana
sulla terra come scandita da quattro
stagioni un'opera che lo consegnerà alla
storia come immortale
Ebbene non sappiamo esattamente che cosa
scriverebbe oggi Vivaldi se dovesse
vivere quello che viviamo noi e vedere
quello che viviamo Noi forse scriverebbe
che non ci sono più le stagioni di una
volta ma in realtà possiamo ascoltare
Come si trasformerebbero Le quattro
stagioni di Vivaldi alla luce dei
cambiamenti climatici perché una
collaborazione tra scienziati del clima
e musicisti ha utilizzato l'intelligenza
artificiale per riscrivere la partitura
nel caso in cui non dovessimo limitare
la temperatura sotto i 2 gradi
centigradi entro il 2050 Mi è nata
un'opera che si chiama diansure than
Season le stagioni incerte e musica il
nuovo Vivaldi nell'anno 2050 Se quindi
la Primavera di Vivaldi suonava così
[Musica]
nel 2050 suona così
questo perché
la freschezza della Primavera Lascia il
posto ad un incertezza l'incertezza dei
raccolti perché la biodiversità è stata
persa e la spensieratezza invece
dell'estate Lascia il posto alla
violenza dei nubifragi all'oppressione
delle ondate di calore che trasformano
ciò che conosciamo
trasformandolo Addirittura in termini di
colore da Verde a quasi marroncino
la delicatezza dell'inverno invece
Lascia il posto all'imprevedibilità dei
venti ma l'autunno se è possibile quello
che a me personalmente ha colpito di più
perché Vivaldi Scrive nella sua
partitura che l'autunno comincia con la
legge Adria del della vendemmia invece
Indian Seasons l'autunno non suona
l'orchestra è muta gli orchestrali sono
seduti e non procedono a produrre alcuna
nota E questo perché in alcune aree del
mondo non vi sarà alcun autunno e in
effetti non vi sarà alcuna stagione
Perché in assenza di piani di
adattamento adeguati e in assenza di uno
sforzo globale per ridurre le emissioni
da gas serra alcuni luoghi del mondo
scompariranno è il caso delle isole
Marshall ad esempio che sono un piccolo
Stato insulare dell'oceania dove 60.000
persone saranno costrette a migrare e
quel numero quello dei rifugiati
climatici è destinato ad aumentare
perché previsioni
particolarmente attendibili parlano di
1.2 miliardi di rifugiati climatici
entro il 2050
vuole naturale che con queste premesse
voi possiate pensare che il nostro sia
un destino completamente segnato non ci
sia letteralmente niente da fare e
invece no perché noi viviamo questa
situazione che continueremo a vivere per
effetto di due forzanti importanti La
prima è una componente naturale la
naturale variabilità climatica che vuole
i gas serra come nostri alleati della
vita sulla terra nello specifico
250 anni fa c'erano nell'atmosfera 280
Parti per milione di diossido di
carbonio cioè il gas serra di cui
sentite parlare costantemente la
cosiddetta CO2
oggi Quel numero è a 416 Parti per
milione ora Io non vorrei veramente
questa sede rivelare la mia età però per
questa causa lo faccio questo ed altro e
quindi sono nata 32 anni fa a 354 Parti
per milione Oggi siamo a 416 siamo
riusciti ad arrivare a quel numero in 32
anni ma la terra in assenza dell'uomo
aveva avuto uno scostamento così grande
solo in 10 milioni di anni quindi se
dovessi rivelare la mia età in aumento
di Parti per milione Oggi avrei 10
milioni di anni
ovviamente uso delle ottime creme che vi
posso eventualmente consigliare alla
fine di questo intervento
ebbene la domanda però è come riusciamo
ad invertire la rotta o in qualche modo
avere a che fare con delle soluzioni
oltre che con dei problemi cioè come
evitiamo dato che siamo già passati
nella parte più rossa di questo schema
come evitiamo di finire in quella parte
ansiogena violacea
usando ciò che la scienza ci dice e
facendolo nostro attraverso tre semplici
passaggi Il primo è la presa di
coscienza Ciò che avviene non è alieno
estraneo a noi ci riguarda direttamente
frutto Delle nostre scelte delle nostre
Industrie del nostro stile di vita Il
secondo è che vivere nelle ansie o
vivere nelle quattro stagioni di Vivaldi
comporta delle scelte scelte come
prediligere l'utilizzo delle risorse
rinnovabili e ridurre invece il consumo
di fossili scelte Come investire il
proprio denaro in attività che aiutano
la Terra e il nostro guadagno non che
riducono la natura a una bieca serva
scegliere significa privilegiare il
riutilizzo il riuso il recupero
scegliere significa anche
fare delle scelte di consumo locali
Quindi no le fragole a dicembre non sono
assolutamente un'opzione scegliere
significa anche rivolgersi ai propri
amministratori locali e chiedere che ci
sia in piano in essere una serie di
strategie per far fronte agli impatti
dei cambiamenti che già Viviamo e che
continueremo a vivere
nelle sue città invisibili Italo Calvino
fa parlare Marco Polo con kublaikhan al
termine del libro kublaikhan è
particolarmente stanco come sconfortato
e Marco Polo gli dice che l'inferno dei
viventi se ne esiste uno non è quello
che verrà è l'inferno che è già qui che
abitiamo tutti i giorni che creiamo
Stando insieme due modi ci sono per far
fronte all'inferno Il primo è quello di
accettarlo fino a non vederlo più il
secondo è più rischioso e richiede
attenzione e apprendimento continui cioè
scegliere chi e cosa in mezzo
all'inferno non all'inferno e saperlo
nutrire e dargli spazio e quindi ecco il
terzo punto
per passare dall'impotenza e dalla paura
all'azione ci vuole una critica
e la parola critica deriva dal verbo
greco Crino che dà origine anche ad
un'altra parola italiana la parola crisi
krino significa separare distinguere ma
anche giudicare questionare farsi
domande investigare la crisi climatica
richiede una critica sistema sistemica
la crisi climatica richiede che la
questione diventi una questione
culturale che ci appartenga a tutti la
crisi climatica chiede di usare quello
che sappiamo oggi per decidere che cosa
vogliamo diventare
Grazie
[Applauso]